par un parent papam param param salue
les enfants vous avez remarqué comme je
suis bon aujourd'hui à merci je savais
que vous aviez bon goût pendant la même
tendance en entamant par un parapente
qu'est ce que c'est que ça or on vire à
une pancarte c'est peut-être un message
pour moi voyons cela
ne pas approcher danger danger voilà
peut-être quoi l'arbre rouge a explosé
non non non ce n'est pas possible non
peut-être que mademoiselle futaie est
dans les parages
non elle ne peut pas être par là j'avais
vu de l'autre côté du petit bois coûte à
l'heure alors c'est c'est sans doute
qu'il y à aramon se cacher derrière et
puis sont là derrière oh oui c'est
sûrement ça j'aurais essayé de lui faire
peur un à
s'engueuler gros mosta
il ne sort pas ouf on ne prévient du lit
julie elle a quasiment tu tombe bien tu
vas tu attends attends attends signant
je sais que tu adores me rendre service
bon ben voilà la tâche et riom tiens moi
c'est bongo parce que il ya un kilo de
caramel vous qui vient de disparaître et
je ne sais plus où les ennemis à
personne mais compte à lui seul vaut
certainement
certainement ça
c'est ce que j'essaye de t'expliquer il
ya un gros monstre caché dans les
buissons là bas où dieu me faut prévenir
les sols - les enfants venez vite
résolu c'est ce que j'essaye de tester
vous allez viens nous pourrions
atteindre et koudougou temps allez vous
cacher dans la critique bleu près de la
plage oui georges tron le monstre
d'accord mais saisit bien qu'il soit
prudent cet accord
donnera au monde auplata
cinquièmes sont passés jules et les
enfants kazim kazim tu peux m'expliquer
ce qui se passe
non franchement parents enfants et un
monstre derrière les buissons un monstre
tu l'as vu mais on n'en pas encore mais
c'était le cri ne pas s'approcher danger
casimir mais c'était encore une fois ton
imagination avant cette pancarte c'est
moi qui l'ait mise parce qu'il ya des
boulons de l'arbre boucher dévissé et
que je suis venu le réparer ou c'est
dangereux de montée de ce rémois qui
envoyait julie elle les enfants se
cacher dans la clique bleus
casimir il faut absolument que l'aisne
où aller chercher pendant que l'autre
s'occupe de l'arbre rouge mon bac ou
transitoires 1 ça te fera une promenade
moi je vais travailler dur pendant ce
temps là c'est très gentil de sacrifier
des promenades je te laisse les outils
tient très bien merci 1
julie encore laissé traîner un sac de
caramel
me sacrifier il va faire deux kilomètres
à pied pendant que moi serait resté bien
tranquillement ici
dès qu'on passera quelqu'un je lui
demanderais de resserrer le boulon
attendons je vous préviendrai
vous revenez juste à temps voici
monsieur du snob bonjour mes très chers
jeunes me tiens mais c'est le désert ici
quelle mystérieuse silence
tellement là qu'est ce que c'est c'est
de l'engrais l on veut dire un salut en
anglais je te remercie quasi muet mais
tu sais très bien que je parle
couramment l'anglais
ne soyez pas vexer j'ai un service à
vous demander un c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant passionne un prix il
s'agit d'un resserré à boulon de l'arbre
rouge à part d'autres magasi niamey je
ne m'attends à perdre bon bah tant pis
c'est moi qui aurais la récompense
la récompense oui julie a promis à un
baiser à celui qui ferait ce travail à
dos noir laqué jeunes au travail très
bien mon jeu pour la prévenir bon
courage
voilà c'est terminé il me reste plus
qu'à descendre pour attendre
mademoiselle julie
mais qu'elles aideront à non pas l eau
mais que faites vous dans cet arbre des
ans et demi non je ne peux pas c'est
impossible mais pourquoi ou aux pauvres
petits coléoptères mou vous avez le
vertige
attendez je m'en vais jouer avec les
enfants plus tôt je les enfants ne sont
pas là c'est vrai il emporte avec julie
sont jamais là quand il faut se faire à
l'idée
que ces malades contagieux c'est très
grave malade vous mais c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont partis voyons j'ai à la fois
la jaunisse la rougeole la cathine la
coqueluche et la grippe alors
[Rires]
j'ai aussi des pompiers
bon allez descendre ou ou au secours à
loire à aleg au
secours
je suis coincé lüscher se décoincer
autrement maintenant on passe à la
maison mais c'est vous allez y de sport
à vous sortir tard voilà les enfants
merci
à faire c'est mes chiens sa vie merci
c'était très bien mais tout ça ne serait
pas arrivé si vous étiez resté dans le
jardin oui ils sont jamais là quand on a
besoin d'eux les environs par monsieur
du snob les enfants sont toujours prêts
à rendre service je vais même vous
ordonnez plusieurs exemples à
[Musique]
quand j'ai voulu saluer à la fin du
terrier d'à côté
j'ai mis ma tête dans leur poule mais
coincé jusqu'au bout j'ai tout fait
malheureusement les enfants
contactée
à temps
ils m'ont tiré très fort par les pieds
et j'ai pu respirer
[Musique]
tout en haut d'un mur de pierres
imputant les arv et je dansais
tentez la vie on descend j'ai senti tout
mon sang se glace et
[Musique]
temps
ils ont tendu une ouverture j'aime plus
santé du mur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leurs feux dans l'île aux enfants je
chante joliment mes chansons
si j'ai la voix qui déraille
mémoire qui défaillent
attention 1
enfants
[Applaudissements]
à temps
[Musique]
mais paris
oui
[Musique]
il est quasiment
or
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
ma chère amy je crois que le moment est
venu d'un petit baiser en guise de
récompense
parfaitement monsieur disney
qui à casimir bravo quoi
on ne voyait pas ça non monsieur 19 pour
le boulot que vous avez rangs serrés
c'est moi qui vais vous donner deux
baisers amicaux à venir
[Musique]